vous dites que l'europe a pas de vaccin
mais il ya quand même l'allemagne où il
ya biotech
yatuu revak biotech a sorti ses vaccins
puisque c'est une start up et elle s'est
adossé à pfizer cure baksaas est adossé
à d'autres laboratoires
là où il ya eu un déficit c'est la
france où on comptait sur sanofi mais
sanofi regardez à l'heure actuelle ils
ne financent plus la recherche et
développement
il préfère soit acheter des start up ou
soit surtout faire de la communication
pour vendre les médicaments qui leur
rapportent de l'argent et puis payer
aussi les dividendes aux actionnaires
sanofi n'est plus tellement un promoteur
d'innovation on s'est loupé sur val neva
où ce sont les anglais comptent financer
les études cliniques et quand ils ont
demandé l'aide de la france la france ne
les a pas aidés
donc c'est plutôt je dirais fiasco sur
sanofi pasteur et sanofi va peut-être
sortir un vaccin à la fin de l'année
mais c'est pas un échec sur le plan
européen parce que vous avez quand même
des vaccins européen
et puis l'intérêt aussi d'être sur un
plan européen c'est qu'on a eu un panel
de vaccins possible parce que ça va de
bioéthique files heures à curvalle à
johnson & johnson a modern a et ça on
n'aurait pas pu le faire tout seul donc
un il faut jouer solidarité si on veut
répondre à une pandémie de il faut jouer
groupé et il faut pouvoir justement
apporter ces vaccins tout le monde là où
on a péché c'est ce que je vous disais
c'est que les négociations ont duré très
longtemps pour en plus une
responsabilité une garantie d
anonymisation qui sont pas à la hauteur
puisque les laboratoires ne veulent
absolument pas endosser la
responsabilité les garanties vis-à-vis
de patients qui pourraient avoir des
effets secondaires
c'est ça qui est scandaleux et il ya une
complicité je dirais des états membres
qui ont accepté en fait le bon vouloir
de ses labos qui ont été financés depuis
des années par de l'argent public
[Musique]